the heading is exciting of my tragic
what are we looking at here now
something I always love to tell me is it
mathematicians work hard but we only
ever work hard so we can do that easy we
want to do some minimum of metal so we
can what we as efficient as possible and
that's what this is about like
explaining in factorizing is blood but
the reason it's wettest summer we can
make things easy let me show you there
are a couple of examples we call these
expressions is there equal signs that's
why it's known equation so I would be
able to write these in a simple way now
I noticed one two three four four
tethers every single one is a multiple
of fire this is kind of a pain like if
you go to get up or something whatever
you're ordering like a deep blue you're
like okay
I want 20 this and 20 20 of this what a
pain just saying I'm gonna give you a
list give me 20 and older okay now this
is the same thing is happening here
every single one has a 5 in common I
need to write those 5 so many times I
just need about them once and then if I
put brackets in place like this is the
pinnacle of mathematical ways in history
after saying do that to everything in it
and while they're riding at native
everybody's okay so we're gonna factor
out five for each in turn
you don't need to say it so when you
take the five out of the first time what
do you get that we just yes I'm dividing
thirty-five it's not as they confuse
divide that by five yeah that's what is
it seven and I can keep going all the
way through right I can go that'll be a
minus y squared
don't forget the sign and then on the
end that looks like 2-1 to me now
admittedly this is a bit of a contrived
example the benefit is not that huge
because we're kind of practicing the
skill that itself before we see the
implication part but it's all means
right
five times all of that that's a
coefficient that is the factor I
factorize thing out you can do pretty
rules as well have a look 16 to the 5
minus 14 T cube plus T squared I'm
looking for a factor what do I see
income between every one of the three
terms okay I have a tea I can do better
than tea though Akana
in fact there's my tea tea is 3 then
there's two Nick yeah so I can take out
two of them right so I'm gonna write T
swear out the front so it's gonna calm
that index or this is a bit tricky but
doing a couple of skills at once this is
really don't write this big but this is
really shorthand as well it seeks TTT
to UT right five of them so if I'm
taking two out how many are left
6d cute this is why the index law of
like always subtract the palatal and
that's why it works is because it's just
shorthand for this there are three of
them here so when you take out two over
you're left with just one of them don't
forget that minus 14 hangs on to the
right there because I haven't done
anything to factorize that out and then
of course lastly what's left okay now
careful we're dividing not subtracting
right so when you divide this by T
Square it's a lot okay so if we were
subtracting it would come out to zero
but we are not subtracting we factorize
it if defining okay so that's all there
is to factorize and we'll have a look at
the exercise in okay but these kind of
come in ISM the two sides of the same
coin that happens all the time in maths
right you could the same ID from two
different angles because you know what
factorizing not always the greatest and
we said it's a great shortcut it's great
to be lazy but it can lead to a problem
tell look at this expression now I know
just by looking at these right do you
remember a couple lessons again we
looked at collecting like terms remember
that I have some like types in here do
you see them where are they there's the
X's right I've got one victimized and
I've got one of them so these are like
terms I should be able to make this
simple but kind of hard right now
because this sort of walked into
brackets they have been factorized and
now I kind of get at them so what do I
do is how to open stuff back up
I want to make all this expanding right
or you get rid of all the brackets open
everything up and then the extra
like what sentence I should get
something set up here so remembering
what we trees brackets for right it's
five times all that or it's T squared
times all that I'm just going to do the
same thing here right this one means
four times both of those guys yeah and
this would be five times both of those
guys so I'm going to get rid of my
brackets who was that what four times x
squared
four times minus X their excitement
minus 4x
they said that guys can factorize and
you can see by like before I go any
further have I seen those two trailers
like there's none of these questions I
would say oh you can't I can factorize
that I can take the four out if I can do
more what else could I take out I can
take it next vote if I wanted to
I've expanded the first pair of brackets
now I'll do the second pair by context
and by that time I'm like okay so now
you can see that collecting like terms
that I was after before it's really easy
like they're literally right next to
each other okay so these guys plus 4x
plus 5x this is what I end up okay so
we're not expanding just because just
for the lawls
because I can write the whole point is
if I expand sometimes I can lead to
something simpler I can get it something
which is gonna become nicer at least
gets right I think we all agree this is
much better time